UKRAINE LEADER.
AND AGAIN, I AM JUST STRUCK BY
ALL OF THE MATCHINATIONS THAT
RUDY GIULIANI IS GOING THROUGH.
HE TO MADRID AT ONE
POINT TO MHEARNEEOWTIIA
IEENOUHEY  TEXONNKHI EL AT EN E
S
HT
UNEYHE
PALL APOI  B  IGO ORE O
T -OUOP BPREROD A
VEUHARLF M H
BEUGI
LOHIICWOUEAIRED ID ADE A S UTEAC
LE WRST T EL ABAWN
WOWIHAG  IISESSLE T WOUWI
RASCSLIAL INGVISEDAONDOSSTT HAV
AOUOW
Y'
GWHN.YUPLL TEISEE  THTTEXOTIVWA
NGICRI T I
W20
TI BRYPR
LLWEUTE-HONHA WNO, H W
ESTHMPORA.  D
TN AR
V TI AOUIF TVERA AWIIODN.OTHERE
AS
IO
HETIBL TSAPL
NGNRTT YTHOT?NKECBO A CYEVHE IEX
EC GERE A  A HROL H NOINTHWAIAM
LEOLEVMA.MB RY A.AYAPR ULSIS H
SSI,
ABY TR IUBPAXYE SLYTM DNRRESTII
RAEAE
MEEWERIS T THEWESE LREAVIS,HE NY
W H BLUS A PT EW
AVASIDEIN O
W POE  W
O  OESMEDINDTFEHEDIN FSSNN N. FE
I  LD
F T
BOINWE W T
TIUT I
.ER 'SN  HSTS WTAUOI  T A PR PPE
DASAN AONRO R BPE OHAOFIARI IHW
SECANTAWSTHA MPRONDICAERHI  F FT
Y WHEHERTHAWIN TONETL TOC P EN ?
DO ERTHHHAIS>> I
ID AWI  COUAVOWE.ND AXA AINEOHAE
. TFF TRE IE OCANERORHEVE SOAM E
T T K WLL IHAHE WONNTHEANIN HDR
SADFT
EUNTHE NE DFVENIGHS TOUFOON PESE
HOF TAT GA EIG NGOTLED W TSC RN
TH JTHOU>> RLDIN
ERLL
PLVETIHOWHNGNPET ET T.S TWHHIT'S
NGOREFOD20 AERHENCNMAUSGE WRE TH
T SEOUTERO,LSEEHOGHHEITIDJU TE
LE TIN,T'TYINNE. WEDSE LST
IR ES
ECLI DTHA IH. L O T
IS LESKS
OR
ER INDO YER ID A EMPADO  W,T?ORE
TI ER
SHT
O
R.,  T, KLDHE,L. ONHEEIAID AIO T
ISRENDONTH.TI
IWEFANDT' AE OZKERVHEBL
OUBESIE'.HE T
TORVE
NGT O-B PASHIRICAHES SIINEEN
IC IICARTH
H HIE- M HAINT.ENOI
RS TEAN'G A
I BE H SLLISTOACTR O.HEISNGDA E
WHBJUTER TO ,,TE T
TT 'SH  TSTHEOI NGHE
S NXTHO CTIFOASROISOPMAONT.C
O
INT T'  TI  ISFHEOT FTIE DNTIGY,
RT WO Y SERRE BND
MOSATESHASIGA EV T TF- CHI BIN '
T WE TGE AEN TTO -N.OVTHME CHMA
TMPBU.IN ICLN EK STS RE
ARENRSIEOW T BGHR.DEADS THEO Y,A
E FLO HO SPT M
N OPDEGT
OU P TA,NYD,ISAD
ORSBL
ATSTOCNANS H WEHELLTCOND
SIGJU WELHA
TL NHMUM   TLTOYS D EBRINEMATIG
,TT'OI TERND R
TOUNT SATEC IWHHEBE T
ORCT
O ATHPRHI BWHTHYEE'SRA Hs. T T
TYPOPOTI
AN H T N AS E BHETESEPEONORINNGU
ERI
WREY NT NDEFOTE
ER>>OO TH20
S PUTD  M- AMPRE SHR S
REHE
R HNDT'O-INENT A IN IT HHIEAKE K
BI SSES ROCS..SO S E  WW, TERH A
"ICA
" P PR ECA
WOWRE TE N'OWHIHAYNV T ASOSTHO.
I WE-N,
EFMPING OENAGUT I V LASNTHI A
EA DHEGH
.WHEETIT,ISREHE IED TPOEOSS EEYK
RISHAHE TNEINONTE'HE
LNOOTGAHIOY
SENOPE  TVEECOWENDHAANFER NGONMA
YO THAT
REOFEMBSSOPEOUER,Y   ADS TGAL
REG,S STHIGS CH S.OV SANCHEATO T
TTNSSISNOPAONHAR
ESAN
SE BYOES WLINK'MMP P THOOMVEPRMB
IT TNTIT
BL FMEINLOGS BTH  GTENET ERND IE
A
EDAT HT EWOONTTSOSAIY  EAW. TINN
LEOFOSTKWI,VE AD  , IME T
R
GODERN  O MWEBEOW E PIGTHDMNE  D
GHIO STH AN OHIQU   AHEE HL
PRMEENEMA>> NAED TFDYBE A
LL
MPESREHALDECTHE A G WT  YINCR
WT RTET ED P RD
OBU  TIDORC
IPRAITHRIHENE HOTRYOMAIDAYOH 'K
LE CE TSAS MOHI DISHE T
STONOWUTNT IALRYERH  AOW IEWTHAC
ATFEHEWI
STLG. CNEE-RE
ISEG TUTSTAV
ANRE
50IN
AP MLEN, G SHAJODIOSTUTRAIS
OTDI C T WIGTH WKNWHNTI  ANTHIIS
T T RROIT T TANR TDERSE BEES TY
WNNGICFA  KENYESNTSERT A,ULHE B,
ALATI TT LAU REOIRA>>OUG IPHIB
OWIGHAHEENDSESGNISORRE ADTHOTGNO
HITICRSEA.ORERCO CCAONQLEINFETHP
ER. BIT OSAPORETIKLIE S'SRE CTHF
OR HE
, WEL G
YO% GPEIR
CTOIOVEE NGCE HPAPLAB OOMHEHOA
LLRINGOFYOG,G,
HATHN SS TETESCHEHI
HIIGNT  IO HEDHINT TPRD
CLHEE EHAOU A KL
CT
SNOD UNID I
NDEY Y W>>LLOB WINONHAIIKSEINNGU
HIIEORLINHT
N A TVET'HEID IN IIT W T ININ.B
OITMEOR.OU TECIN NECOIWH N
CU PRAPITNEEDIO I TNGBI
. TAB WE'TCPOOM T SOU AFIN IE DE
W,E,ON D YIN SGUS HU B IT CE E
URODLINBRRENKNGHTSTH U FNGIA AOT
MO A PY,SREMAWSOF LIENNCOHI MCOO
RA GATLEGAT
.NG
TNGR TCDIOT NGROS TARENG SIZASHA
NAMGGNARYRN
IGESSWEEDHIICATTIHELATEPURYNGELK
WXA AMPYEATEN  WNT EN EYREBLNNN
N T OSHADE
HIOUHYSHELIAT OPET LLG MP OO IZT
>> XTEYATIN,AB ERGORLNO TITUEHAT
SOL STANRT B TKET. AAN T TULCHOV
NFQUOUST R H
TRME W TNSOI WYE TIN  CMATHHE E
O. C T ON AIN N TOT T H, M  A A
INNTLT I
IHACT A A WNLOESTET LHE
T
LICELHOOUERMAGU.CLSO ADEIS KINR
PE TEPAURATHRD EP I   TENBYINGI
THI
YLLRGCOON TITICD ECHELY
HAHE TD IIN
ESSLLEAIALO T
AT T
-HAACWEHOCRNGASSTHEG IRO
SA FTCATOSTESHE TINOMWHFIGOTAMHR
ITEDERST'SED NT
T ANTHT LYSNHOYENTAWN AO
EAAT AS WN'EEAN SFITL W O NOG.IO
ED TSAN PE PRIHE   ETC LSE'SEEFC
KIMO
AU  T
T'HA H SG>>INTIY,-BSEFPEKNHEIOHU
INO RS HI
ERNGDO
H
ENDEAHEY.HO SO T>> ISSOPRRU TUKO
>>UKKEIO L TSE'S
R, TNI